hi I'm Erik Bosse and glass is the
latest movie from the M night Shyamalan
verse of grounded superhero characters
from unbreakable and split maybe someday
the sixth sense I'd love to see seeing
dead people as a superpower instead of a
crippling curse for people like me glass
like his two predecessors is a movie
about how comic book characters would
work in the real world so naturally it's
filled with little Easter eggs
references to comics and interesting
visual details that shamans snuck into
the filmmaking
so let's rewatch this movie scene by
seed to point out anything that you
might have missed in spoiler warning in
case you haven't seen the movie yet
okay this movie opens with David Dunn
Bruce Willis the hero of an breakable
now moonlighting as a vigilante
nicknamed the overseer he cameo at the
end of split revealing that movie to be
a sequel to unbreakable the movie where
he survived the crash of a 301 77 and
learned of his invulnerability ability
to see others sins through physical
contact and weakness to water in this
opening scene he doles out justice to
these two jerks whom a cruel prank
videos a move called the Superman punch
this is the first of many examples of
the way comic book characters in reality
intersect in this world the most famous
superhero is being linked with street
violence establishing that whole fear
that dr. staples organization uses to
justify its objectives also these dudes
bastardization of Superman's goodness is
turned on its head when this world's
Superman the overseer gives them a
beatdown
we see that David previously a security
guard and unbreakable now it's his own
security company that he runs with his
son Joseph Spencer treat Clark returning
from the first movie
and notice how the company sign is green
and that green it's very much David's
color everything in his kitchen is dark
green raincoat is pastel green and make
clothes
Shyamalan chose the color green for
David because it's associated with
life-giving properties and David
protects life meanwhile you'll notice
shades of yellow for Kevin crumb ogre or
mustard because that color is associated
with religious ceremonies and Hinduism
and Buddhism like picture amongst road
and Shyamalan saw the Beast as an
evangelist and of course Elijah is
cloaked in purple a color associated
with royalty
majestic qualities because the live just
sees himself as important very high
status I'll talk more later about how
color plays into this movie so early on
in the story Shyamalan makes his
standard director cameo as a customer in
this security store
security guard talking about how a
tenant was murdered off-site so this guy
is Jay Shama Lance cameo as a security
guard in dr. Fletcher's building and
split
so Fletcher was the tenant he's
referring to who died off-site but then
Jay recognizes David from his days
working at the stadium confessing that
he used to hang out with a shady crowd
back then so Shyamalan is also making a
direct call back to his cameo scene and
unbreakable the guy that David searched
for drugs when he saw through contact
that he was dealing in the stadium he's
linking all three cameos in the same
continuity they're all the same guy
David's walks lead him to bump into
Kevin Crum the Horde played by James
McAvoy leading to David rescuing these
kidnap cheerleaders and these two men
fighting
notice how this time kevin has kidnapped
four teenage girls
escalated by one from the three
kidnapped and split now missile conflict
was actually written for the final act
of unbreakable Shyamalan wanted to
introduce the Horde in that movie but he
wasn't able to fit him in and do all the
character development that he wanted so
years later he made split to introduce
Kevin and his whole condition and then
delivered on this showdown between him
and David in the first acting class
now all the camera movement of this
fight is very interesting to see there
are several mounted shots on the actors
with a camera fixed on them and their
movement there's also this offsetting
cut from the beasts upside down point of
view Shyamalan director of photography
for this movie was Mike geolock Asst
sorry for his pronounce that this guy
shot the horror film it follows and you
can see how the two movies share an
unnerving visual aesthetic and as the
Beast fights you can see that he has two
scars on his torso these were from the
shotgun blast that Casey fired at him at
the in a split as the fight spills
outside David and Kevin are surrounded
by police led by dr. le staple Sarah
paulsen she specializes and people who
experience delusions that they have
superpowers dr. Fletcher and split
actually referred to a colleague who
conducted this kind of research maybe
staple is that colleague leaders staple
finds dr. Fletcher's note in Kevin's
file Shaklee written to say his name
which is what she wrote as she was dying
so David and Kevin get admitted to the
Ravenhill Memorial psychiatric Research
Hospital on the security camera feed you
can see the code h2o appearing in the
corner as David has brought in this
could be a nod to water David's
kryptonite which staple weapon eise's
and David sell to keep him at bay and of
course it's the same water from the
spilled tank that kills david outside
later and chemin SEL staple secures him
with this hypnosis light which flashes
to essentially change a channel among
his various identities now we met some
of these identities in split but in
glass apparently 21 of the 24
personalities appear on screen so
returning for the first movie our hedwig
the 9 year old identity Dennis the
dangerous pedophile Patricia the
sadistic English woman the Beast of
course the super-strong animalistic
identity Barry is also in there remember
he's the benign fashion designer
identity who wanted to protect Kevin
also returned meaner or well the
historian and Jade the diabetic she
appears again in class briefly lose him
use of her legs and flirting with the
tall orderly who else to meet a bunch of
new identities there's Luke nice arm
Alon said that this guy is based on a
real-life person Lucci Orochi an editor
from the night Shyamalan last three
movies this guy apparently has a bad
habit of spoiling the ends of movies
there's also mr. Pritchard a professor
of Japanese cinema Norma a well mannered
southern woman Mary Reynolds and her
twin and maybe it's in McAvoy said that
he based one personality on the Irish
actor Saoirse Ronan whom he worked with
an atonement that could be Mary Reynolds
there's also this bro a guy that could
be bTW there's a spanish-speaking figure
that could be Samuel and one with the
German accent Heinrich and there's some
other identities cat Jalen Lita Goddard
and Polly now in a so you can actually
see that he is 23 2001 for each of his
identities also in this facilities of
course Elijah price mr. glass himself
samuel l.jackson the villain mastermind
with brittle bone disease now for the
whole first half of this movie he
appears to be relatively comatose in his
wheelchair but Jackson actually snuck in
a very subtle acting choice to hint at
the scheming going on behind the scenes
before I get to that this video was
sponsored by expressvpn so a VPN allows
you to browse the internet with privacy
without things like company user hackers
spyware shadowy ancient organizations
who don't want the world to know that
superheroes exist any of these things
from tracking your data and secretly
filtering your internet experience
expressvpn masks your IP address to make
sure you aren't being monitored so you
can have that peace of mind you can live
life knowing that no one's peeping on
you expressvpn is the fastest VPN on the
market and the number one VPN service
rated by tech radar and say
in a different country I was actually in
the UK recently and I wouldn't have been
able to access everything on Netflix or
YouTube other streaming services
thanks to expressvpn I could avoid all
these weird restrictions and just watch
everything that I want to do normally
the way the Internet should be wherever
you are
expressvpn lets you securely stream or
download content from anywhere anytime
it's less than seven dollars a month
with the 30-day money-back guarantee
take back your internet privacy today
and find out how you can get three
months free by clicking on the link in
the description box expressvpn comm
slash new rock stars
that's exp ress VPN comm slash new rock
stars for three months with a one-year
package visit expressvpn comm slash new
rock stars learn more take back here
privacy today
okay back to Elijah if you look closely
you'll notice that Jackson makes these
subtle little ticks and his lips as
cheeks his eyes his performance is very
similar to the character hector
salamanca and Breaking Bad and better
call Saul he similarly had these little
facial muscle spasms but he also was a
seemingly harmless old man in a
wheelchair who's actually hiding a
deadly secret weapon to get revenge on
the captors who abused him Joseph tries
to get his father released and afterward
in the car there's a quick flashback
showing a younger Bruce Willis coming in
to talk to him as a boy this was
actually a deleted scene from
unbreakable Shyamalan also featured
another flashback scene with Elijah as a
boy injuring himself in a carnival ride
this was also a sequence that was cut
from unbreakable also in this movie is
Casey cook on a Taylor Joyce character
from split the girl the Beast let go you
can see that she still wears the
employee jacket from the Philadelphia
Zoo that was the one the man who found
her at the end of split gave toward
where there's also a quick scene with
Joseph at the gym he sees a big guy
benchpress in a ton of weight this is a
callback to the scene in unbreakable
when a younger Joseph and David
benchpress over 350 pounds halfway
through the movie staple sits down with
a three patients and notice the pastel
pink color of the background
what kind of psychiatric hospital is
painted this color don't you want people
to get better this is actually another
color device used by Shyamalan he used
the color pink to show how color was
draining from red into white to this
neutral monochromatic place to reflect
how staples manipulations were draining
power from these three men
institutionalizing them and eventually
seeking to lobotomize away their powers
and similarly despite these men's colors
appearing darker fuller shade
earlier in later parts of the movie here
purple yellow and green are featured in
lighter pastels as if their colors are
being drained along with their powers
meanwhile Casey visits this comic book
store and this is the same store with
the same clerk as the one that Elijah
visited and unbreakable
this clerk accuses Joseph as being one
of those Hello Kitty pervs calling back
the line in the earlier film know people
like Hello Kitty that much no king
shaming here this shop is filled with
titles from DC and Marvel including
x-men Doctor Strange and Thor there's
also a statue of the character magic
from the New Mutants which caused Anya
Taylor joy to break character when she
ran into it because that's a character
she's gonna play in the new upcoming New
Mutants movie and of course you'll
notice that this story is the same green
vs. purple color palette as David and
Elijah with a green neon light for the
heroes section and a purple neon light
for the villain section now one of the
covers that catches Joseph's eye is the
whisper man it has this evil presence
whispering the smaller figures and
controlling them kind of like
marionettes now it poses the question
who are his parents which inspires
Joseph to go look up who Kevin crumbs
parents were but the visuals here seem
to be foreshadowing the reveal of dr.
staple as the villain she is a malicious
presence who manipulates superheroes
with her whispering words trying to keep
them under her control later in the
movie dr. staple will actually visit the
same shop and on a TV in the background
of that scene there's an episode of the
60s Batman TV series one featuring the
penguin now back in the facility at
night Elijah escapes from cell he rolls
around and he sees a magazine for the
opening of osaka tower in downtown
Philly this is the destination that
he'll later promised to stage his
showdown and promised to blow it up to
notice how the magazine calls it a
Marvel huh also Osaka tower could be a
nod to the Nakatomi tower in the Bruce
Willis movie die hard it's as if glass
is deliberately trying to build up our
expectations of a big explosive Bruce
Willis showdown a type of skyscraper of
course glass subverts this expectation
with Elijah misdirecting all of us as
part of his master plan and this movie
is meant to be a much more grounded tale
about superheroes in the real world even
though it's a bit of a bummer to never
see a chuckles gun payoff Elijah just
seemingly allows staple to lobotomize
him because really he had already
removed the lasers focus lens and he
does all this in order to lure in
that orderly Darrell so that he can
murder him and get out Elijah's tactics
here pretty similar to the Joker another
purple clad comic-book mastermind the
Joker escaped from Arkham Asylum for the
criminally insane and the Dark Knight
Returns comic and in Christopher Nolan's
movie The Dark Knight Heath Ledger's
Joker uses a broken shard of glass for
his escape just like Elijah does here
and notice how Elijah kills the orderly
he says the words not knowing why you're
here is a terrible feeling that line is
a callback to Elijah's confession to
David at the end of unbreakable not know
why are you here it's just an awful
feeling
Elijah rolls over to Kevin's cell and
dismantles his hypnosis light and notice
how the two of them discuss a particular
art related concept the use of violent
storms in the distance was a common
practice paintings particularly
interesting remember Elijah was an avid
collector of comic book related art so
he is an art nerd in the American
sublime is a collection at the
Pennsylvania Academy of Fine Arts in
Philadelphia with famous works by JMW
Turner Thomas Cole many others Shyamalan
references it here to hint at the coming
storm of Elijah's machinations to unveil
super-powered individuals to the public
and change the world this whole section
of the movie Elijah and Kevin's escape
is narrated by Elijah's view of the
world through the lens of comic book
obsession that sounds like the bad guys
teaming up this is where they would
paint you with big eyes and bubbles of
confusion above your head what didn't
belong in there but thanks for comin
now all these comic book II lines sound
a bit goofy at first but by the end of
the movie Elijah's conspiracy theories
are vindicated because in this world
comic book media does actually reflect
real superhero stories now for a deeper
explanation of this movies ending how
exactly Elijah's plan worked and what
dr. staples clover tattoo and the
shamrock society is all about go check
out my glass ending explain video but
one thing I want to point out here is
that anti superhero society might be
based on the villainous organizations
from the x-men comics ones like the
Friends of humanity they also aim to
stamp out mutants from society claiming
to do so to protect the safety of normal
humans this movie ends
where the trilogy began with eastrail
177 Joseph reveals that Kevin Chrome's
father died in the same train crash that
David survived the one that Elijah
caused and in the final scene
Joseph Casey and Elijah's mother sit in
30th Street train station where this
story began so that they can watch as
the world realizes superheroes actually
exist
earlier Casey argued that Kevin
super-strength could be real citing that
in Action Comics number one the birth of
Superman Superman didn't fly yet and
that the city of Metropolis was based on
New York City saying that the world of
comics and the real worlds are one in
the same and this closing shot pays off
that Man of Steel parallel added
bookends the Superman shot out in the
opening scene with one Last Man of Steel
reference over in the corner on a TV
screen you can see news footage showing
Kevin lifting a car off the ground just
like Superman does on the cover of
Action Comics number one revealing this
movie to be an origin story a number one
first issue of a new era of superhero
legend now the review is an audience
reaction for glass is pretty mixed so do
you think critics are being fair to this
movie comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Twitter for all
the new rock stars on Twitter and two
big announcements for you guys first
announcement new rockstars is launching
a podcast
it'll be an entire new rockstars network
and we're gonna start with a weekly
round table discussion covering all the
nerdy news from the week go ahead and
find new rockstars anywhere you get your
podcasts actually if you use the
Himalaya app we'd appreciate it if you
subscribe to us there because the more
people who subbed through Himalaya the
more Himalaya will help us expand our
podcast network and bring you fun new
shows and second announcement if you
live in the LA area I will be hosting a
new live comedy show every first Friday
of the month called darkest timeline
comedy it'll be a place where I and my
hilarious buddies make you laugh with
the craziest nerd humor you gotta be
there to see it our first show will be
February 1st at the Acme theatre in
North Hollywood thanks for watching this
video and I'm gonna check out some hello
kitty don't judge
[Music]